that's four that's four in March now
just you know everyone acknowledges that
Justin Martyr makes a bad comparison but
he's a prophet he's so come on I need an
ox mush
[Music]
that's I decided to kill my dad who ate
a minute wait a minute
what's going on here ladies and
gentlemen and I decided to do it in a
brutal fashion not a not a gunshot or
anything I was gonna do with a hammer
when I walked up to my dad I've got a
hammer in my hand and I hit him in the
head seven or eight times with a
ball-peen hammer until I thought he was
dead and I just left that's it well how
much is this Honey Chisholm's my son
what the wood I'm gonna smash a
different kind of wood intellectually
hmm
follow me follow me dear friends welcome
to this video in shava in this little
set that we have in our studio we're
gonna be discussing difference questions
and answering doubts
one of those is it's something that I
was predicting that's going to happen
okay so obviously who is dealing with
dealing with somebody called rotten
would you say me now this is somebody
who has actually and this is like
actually mind boggling that he himself
beat well smashed is that hidden when he
was sleeping and tried to attempt to
kill him well so I just want to put into
perspective this person that we're
dealing with has he recovered from the
psychological state I don't fit because
he claims that he's bipolar I don't if
he's using it as an excuse to do further
attacks in the future towards his own
father or his mother to excuse and say I
was mentally not well he always says
this you know even when he's activated
him and destroyed him you're finished he
said you know I'm bipolar oh no no I
don't know why he keeps saying that yeah
because we know apparently you are and
you can see from his face is very hasn't
really still face and this
so it's very scary anyway there's a
different stuck in this different stuff
we're just a stranger let's go to the
academics at home in is you can call it
yeah of somebody that deserves
when it comes to 100 percent the rate is
100 chickens consider eating a person
and his characteristics is will being a
psychological being so I have to pull a
dress I think half of oh please don't
have to share because to be honest with
you anyone with a higher of self-respect
will never engage with a person like
this whenever watches videos it's quite
shameful that many of the Duat the
Christian do around the corners to
Christianity in speakers corner no no
not all of them but the hate-filled ones
and then she is slamming at once yes
they pretty much they seemingly worship
this person I mean I don't know it may
observe every single video and they try
and bring his arguments for the park and
it is that very shameful exactly the
fingers share we're trying to do video
but the thing is once in fact one who
have seen with these Christians who are
hate-filled
on confuse him tunic Allah says Muhammad
Sawa of course with these people like
the hijab sit in this video he said with
Christianity slap you guys have gone
down you don't talk about Christianity
Nemo yes and now you wanna take a stand
on wheels and that's exactly what's
happening here
they have stop talking about
Christianity yeah his whole with he
didn't take the frerp cross that he knew
I was gonna have to give you a free
Arabic lesson here today when you put in
your pleasure from it or animosity grows
so we find that it's not actually a
newer commitment if they're in a buffer
zone from I had many moody and many key
from the fifth-century many others kind
of mentioned is that if you're out there
on time that the marriage wasn't
consummated for those three years and
all the fur to reach puberty etc etc so
it's our ignorance that we came up with
something that the scholars already told
so we didn't read into it we didn't even
know yeah anyways so this was something
that hamdulillah that this video short
and it was very
problematic for this guy rotten wood so
it was so problematic and the fact that
he done a video trying to address and
debunk it shows that is actually working
because a young girl came to Islam
couple of weeks ago and she had this
stuff so you can see people with a
critical mind they don't think the way
he does because this guy here that I
talk to on this video he said yep that's
perfectly makes sense to me that girl
actually came to Istanbul so now
somebody with a sister see exactly do
you see the difference so now he rotten
wood found this problematic this is one
of the biggest arguments they use so
they follow can't use this anymore so so
now what his coming would share is that
more than a second he's using the Koran
ayah you know that chapters 65 verse
post from a mistaken that it says that
pre Besant prepubescent goes well yeah
yes well that yeah so when you marry
them when you divorce them yeah
he said hold on a second Allah mentions
here that girls that don't mistreat so
that means that you're talking about a
young girl so you can marry girls that
they haven't reached to enjoy it's
interesting because this is actually a
rod for the Quran ease those who rely
only on the Quran we only say the Quran
Allah told hadith because yes we're not
for the other Hadi yeah then a lot a
parent of the prom of this area is is
that you can marry some of these pre
president so we saw is it's really only
the hadith so well kill two birds one
stone so then how do we tackle this so
for example what exactly does he claim
him he's claiming that mean kaffir the
Mufasa rune yeah
Vaseline they are saying that you can
marry a prepubescent child yes and he's
using a Koran tire yeah and then you use
another area where he says specifically
this everyone just keep he says I will
come to this one he says that for
example if I was called a bit further he
said that there's a hadith that says
there's no same time so he said in the
razor but I sure I used to play with the
dogs in this presence of the Prophet and
I've your friends used to play with me
when I lost message I used to enter that
my dwelling place solar they used to
hide themselves but the Prophet will
call them to join him play with me
that's when the hadith and so he's using
this
argument to say that women and she was
prepubescent penis only prepubescent
girls can play with the images yes the
dolls that had images in them exact
thoughts on his argument is the
following images are pretty yes yeah yes
yeah I mean if he had because these are
the words of this is the translator
yeah
he mentioned some of them once all its
abrogated okay and it's a medicated
basis is what for to get any strong what
people understand images if this hadith
contained images within that the images
the other ruining of it being Haram
segregated okay so so what he's saying
is he's using evidence that's abrogated
yes yeah okay that's one opinion that's
one opinion another pin he also mentions
that and the second Memon is saying his
book soon and kübra which is a clip from
hadith
he mentions that he also ignore hit burn
and Misty in his story they put heavy
and in the chapter title of course the
film off the scholars of hadith is
present in their chapter titles this is
a comedy thing like the flip of bloody
yes present in how he titles the chapter
that's because I'm glad it wasn't how
did he was a fatigue as well so his book
and it's a book of Phil alright so he if
you look at in the side a promoter and
he mentioned the permissibility of a man
allowing his wife to play with dogs
and he does not mention any particular
age so that's another issue okay shows
that some offices I'm held it's
permissible to play with these dogs
another thing another third opinion that
he mentions that he quotes from someone
called enemy and others that it's
possible that this hadith if what is
meant by the dogs adults that have
images in them then this was before was
made Haram it was before Haram if it
meant if it was after it was made her on
that he said it's possible that Dawn's
may be cool dog very simple may be
called dolls but they have no images in
them okay so let me get this right name
is summarized so missing what you've
seen is this happy fear when I should
play with dolls yes there's these
aspects which number one it was
abrogated pause the show indicates the
fact that she was under the age of she
has to be under age of puberty yes
because it was abrogated she was playing
with it absolutely and number two is
that no it was dose that she played with
but they had no human features
that's what is allowed that's one of the
jobs number three number three is that
we're itching to say yeah some say it's
permissible to proposals in respectful
for the age okay okay okay so number
three is that you can play with dolls
irrespective of the age yesterday my
wife to be hesitate number four is
actually quite interesting yeah that he
mentions dimensions so never know what
is in this area as well that this had is
actually powerful wrong the hadith it's
a longer story and that's quite
interesting yes and that's Kalani he's
mentioned in this and what did he
mention mentions that this hadith the
logo of the hadith is and if he saw some
came back yes after the Battle of Tabuk
okay / okay and in the time of three but
he mention I was definitely around
fourteen years old at the Battle of
Hagar
favored mini the track a one second so
high burn turbo was before hyper now
hyper yes so let's say up whenever you
use the book we're going about the hyper
I'm gonna give it's fine fourteen nobody
said it was the book definitely she will
be with you so down so I'm looking about
the highest yeah okay we're gonna give a
voice or Ottumwa to us so let's go there
are fourteen years old
great but wait a minute it says that the
dogs were actually not images at all the
dogs were
three horses with two wings on it and in
fact the story continues the idea
arsonist was seldom he knows what is
this and she said how do you know that
soon a man had these dogs like in a
jokey way some loved yes
okay okay which shows that it was not
even images in the first place so it's
permissible to as and this is what any
me says it's permissible to play with
dolls adults may be called human dolls
or girl dogs yeah but of course they
have no images but even even if you say
argument's sake yeah they would those
even hundred Ascalon you know him Allah
says that she was fourteen fourteen
simple that's that's yeah okay so now
which means she reach puberty
exactly yeah definitely yeah okay so now
that's one point yes
now I found something profound yeah was
thinking man whoa speaking of you sure
there's some brainstorming let's go back
to the Columbus so this is kind of the
ideas and the community here in brackets
is somebody because somebody that's
using it evidence because he believes
this he's trying to use this evidence
yes to prove this point because the
follows more may be stricter what is it
strictly for an opinion if he follows
and he's using that any number the issue
of those images it's quite a complicated
issue is it as simple as people make it
out to be yes there's a whole consequent
the discussion amongst the scholars what
is an image what is an image things I'm
saying boy is actually hard on the
statues for example is that so on and so
forth so it's actually quite detailed
exactly so okay now organs were gonna go
to chapter 65 verse for this is very
profound yeah okay in this was not a
city before at the beginning show he
says that T response ever says that we
knew divorce woman and it talks about
women that menstruating
but then Allah gives talks about those
who are not mistress so now you can
understand this in two ways
number one it can be a woman that
doesn't minister yes but we're gonna go
arguments here yes what what Rosen says
yes yeah okay
give it rotten arguments do you have to
deal with it yeah okay now he's seen
that that means you can marry
prepubescent children yeah so his
argument is this the fact that Allah
says for those who don't you know
ministry that's talking about kills yes
they haven't so I sure couldn't not
reach the age administration now me
personally he done a 22-minute video
yeah I can answer this in 22 seconds
it's great yeah one more time now okay
so
very easy I was sitting on those who
have married yet then get divorced and
unconsummated yeah okay yeah and every
stage of people - yes perfect
if the Prophet married I should at six
yes and at the age of seven yeah firstly
they were Americans okay first they were
married they would not it was not
consummated
she got divorced yes and there was an
administration a girl its success what
he's failing to understand as usual is
that in Islam marriage and consummation
of he thinks that in his Western
married so the issue of consummation yes
exactly and the issue of consummation
issue for home fact there's no Sharia is
with the Sharia sets very carefully what
we can overcome - exactly and what are
the things which not only assert to you
socially progressive or if it's limited
yes it doesn't matter in respecting it
also takes into consideration people's
was mine until it's not there
yeah I mean this the the the principle
is so vast yeah so perfect so many what
we call for so many secondary first come
underneath is one overarching principle
then it's mashallah vertical lawyer
examples of severe now his concern is
pedophilia yes now we need to bring
something tonight here if this issue is
pedophilia now I would really ownership
if I was standing there you know how you
stand the police they take a picture
yeah imagine me and this guy with this
face I mean look at space yeah
if he was standing there and I was
standing here he would fit the profile
of a pedophile with arguments say well I
seen oh yeah white middle-aged man can
be questioned the man part can question
the earth it would fit the profile now
I'm not seeing every single white
middle-aged man fits the profile I'm
trying to make a point here because if
his concern is pedophilia pedophilia is
not a Muslim issue it's not almost in
problem I'll be honest with you it's not
but men look like him and we worship the
way he looks if somebody was to leave
their children he would be the last
person to leave it with not in his own
country quarter of a million girls are
being married under the age yeah so now
this is a problem in his geography yeah
graphically yeah okay so this is your
problem so why is doing now this is
following the dirt on others yes and I
think you need to go back and look at
the top ten Peter files around the world
yeah you would hardly find someone that
looks like me so I think this argument I
think we've buried it six feet it's done
it was that a long time ago brothers to
go to the slam website go to one of my
essays then you'd find her by the book
the woman in the text exactly yes a new
book as well and brothers and sisters
it's done really anyone brothers do you
know anyone who has this rub this down
send them back to us in the matrix we
head back to that essay on Sam Simon
it's done provinces I don't think
there's anything I need to be said
literally it just got this mantle and
you can see once again as usual
yeah it's janessa you know we've
literally hammered him not the way what
he did to his father but in an
intellectual way we do not condone
violence in any way shape or form the
hope he listens to that and may God
protect his father but on the sisters
function watching video I mean all of us
you know
may Allah bless you guys for watching I
hope this will be benefit for you guys
now if you would like me and chef
Melissa to react yeah but you know watch
any videos or if they doubt sister said
are well-pleased inshallah we'll be here
at ceramics Allah and we want to thank
you guys for helping and supporting and
believing in Salaam for us to bring you
these videos in Charlotte hope this has
helped you the way it has helped us till
next time assalamu alaikum what happened
what happened right back yet